if all goes according to plan
by Thursday America will be one small
step closer to sending humans to Mars
that's when NASA is scheduled to launch
the first test flight of its Orion
capsule this week's mission will be
unmanned but Orion is designed to carry
astronauts the more than 30 million
miles it will take to reach the Red
Planet Orion's first journey will be
shorter than that two orbits around the
earth reaching an altitude of 3600 miles
still that's more than 15 times higher
than the International Space Station and
farther than any spacecraft built for
humans has gone since the Apollo moon
missions nearly 40 years ago four hours
and 24 minutes later Orion will return
to Earth reaching speeds of up to 20,000
miles per hour at that velocity Orion's
exterior will reach temperatures near
4,000 degrees Fahrenheit which is why
NASA has equipped the spacecraft with
the largest heat shield ever made
after splashing down in the Pacific
Ocean Orion's next launch isn't
scheduled for another three years
astronauts won't step inside it for
another seven and an actual mission to
Mars is at least twenty years away as a
spacecraft Orion is incredibly fast as a
program it's a bit slower
you